foreign
[Music]
contribute I've got quite a bit this is
a text conversation all right okay just
give me four minutes and I swear all
them pretty little curls are going to be
straightened when I'm done with your
boss reply
why are you texting my girl reply why
are you responding when you know I
wasn't talking to you
that
that's wrong I responding when you know
I wasn't talking to you nah give me your
location immediately we have to scrap
also do you think for a second I'm
replying why you texting me yo bro
that's impossible that's impossible the
phone's in a million pieces
and I'm in Hong Kong yeah yeah facts
yeah because I don't know what I've done
I don't have the metal strike to be
texting anyone but why are you texting
my girl I'm shaking your hair is going
to be straight when I'm done with that
okay
man I didn't reply why are you texting
my girl nah you're you're out of your
mind tax that's crazy talk cool right
I've got one
this one's actually annoying because it
actually uses my name as reference oh
Pig it says Uber be having you outside
looking like a prostitute walking up to
the car like James
that's so fat [__] supposed James
bro the passy oh the Uber had me out
there at like 3 A.M the other day live
it running around running around looking
for it bro and then when you get in it
I'm just like you know when you pull the
door and they lock it yeah yeah and then
you just roll down the window it made me
look like a horse I'm there like for
James for James and they're like yeah
yeah you just hear it again I'll hop in
the back yeah oh that's disgusting yeah
yeah my soul mate probably somewhere
given head right now stop bass spit it
out
stop they spit it out that's right
oh God yo that's funny
oh that's dread but true facts oh yeah
all right I couldn't be cheated on with
head though
uh I'd rather I'd rather just just make
it me feel like it was non-consent yeah
head that is personal head is closed why
are you trying to make him feel good
yeah that's too why are you trying it's
not it's not even about your night
anymore you want him to feel good great
all right um You Got What yeah yeah I've
got a couple more all right hit me grown
men calling roadside assistance for a
flat tire is sassy as [__]
when you're on road and the hazards are
on
person I don't care how Sassy I look if
you think for a second I'm breaking open
that boot to start pumping up the Jack
and just figuring stuff out yo man
you're mad I always on a phone oh 100
bro because I I need if I'm changing
tires I need to be quick with it I need
these man to think oh he's a mechanic
he's a mechanic this is his car is he is
he the assistant yeah you're facts yeah
the thing you know when you take off the
bolts with the little yeah
yeah yeah
that's your job
I'm not changing tires fan [__] all of
that next what's the craziest excuse
your man ever told you for not coming
home at night response he said he was
cleaning his house and mopped himself
into a corner he had to wait he had to
wait for the floor to dry and fell
asleep
oh you're such a liar
like live with common sense yeah 400 bro
recorder that's Joe oh God right yeah
this one's jokes so this is the picture
here yeah
father says he found me crying he crew
too he crew too we both crowed
oh this one is a text conversation
so when do you want to meet up
how about next week let's get to know
each other first QE hahaha okay what you
want to know
what's your favorite sport soccer
ask me a question does it squirt hello
[Laughter]
hello oh man them don't want to learn
nothing at least composure
I just want to clap I don't want to
conversate bro does it squirt you just
Nitty Gritty yeah
it's my favorite sport popping cheeks
bro facts yeah I'm a pro
um this one why do men not so fast reply
I gotta get home to the woman I love I
saw that one today I saw that one two
dead oh that's funny too funny that's
too far gotta get home to the woman I
love that
oh Jesus
Jesus all right this one again
conversation you're hot reply I know I
am reply no you're supposed to be
insecure so I can manipulate you into
wanting my validation oh
flipping Hellman say swear bro madness
Okay another conversation hey handsome
you're lying already bye
you're lying already bye on that
validation team I saw like a
a YouTube thing
like uh some blind date YouTube thing
okay uh on tick tock
a few weeks ago and it was like the
woman asking questions to all demand
them and uh she asked this one guy like
oh
how would you
pause this like how would you act or how
would you deal with like asked if we got
into an argument something
[Music]
my mom was like ah
I'd probably like what do you say
I probably blame you and Gaslight you
um into thinking that argument was your
fault all right
just chatting [__] and was like yeah so
I'd guess like you belittle you
um and then like get you back into like
needing my validation and all this kind
of stuff like they're manipulative stuff
and she was like raw and the next clip
was the the judge being like cool so who
you picking she was like
yeah she wanted it bro women love toxic
men
so backwards yes nice guys finished last
bro they do it's mad
anyway crying over a man who makes your
nipples stink after you suck them is
crazy
[Laughter]
I make your nipples stink that
is crazy
like thus he's got gum disease
man's saliva reeks he's a scarf yourself
that's Bonkers to me
oh my days bro that's one of the
funniest ones I've heard you read oh
women know how to hit the nail of the
head sometimes yeah yeah wow
wow all right there is no better feeling
than someone playing with your hair or
running their fingers down your back
unless you thought you were home alone
yeah I've seen that one before that's
scary stuff
did I tell you I had a ghost in my yard
the other day mate what no you never
what the [__] brother I swear down
I was asleep in the middle of night when
I say I ignored it because I was like if
it's my time it's my time yeah yeah I'd
rather die peacefully yeah then try and
figure out what's about to happen to me
yeah yeah yeah I was asleep like this I
sleep like this on this side
and it was middle of the night yeah when
I say I woke up and turned to this side
something knocked me in my back of my
head no it never I swear to God as I up
like that my head knocked something I
lay down like that and my eyes were like
that
you did it what my eyes was straight
like that yeah
and I thought what's the best case
scenario yeah yeah yeah yeah cause
something's about even someone's about
to grab the back of my head like this
opinion or their Vex that that I caught
the mid robbery yeah and I'm gonna
quietly leave and go away so my eyes
were white like that and I just I just
dazed back down I woke up the next
morning saying bar I Sprint it
downstairs to check everything was in
the right place and it was and I was
like big one thing what was that what
what or whom was that I would have
double tapped my lamp because it's a
touchdown back switch that [__] on
because now it's because I was facing
away from him yeah
foreign
[Laughter]
yeah that was a [__] in my yard bro
I'm starting of it oh [__] bro because I
was facing away from him yeah I knew
that if I react he's gonna grab the neck
back in my neck and then my cheeks are
his for the taking and like I said just
kill me yeah yeah just kill me I don't
want to struggle like that I can't have
that happens because it obviously got a
game plan you're not just in my room to
be here fat you want to start them it
reminded me of when I said to you at
Joyce's thing in the after fight I was
like what would you do if my man pinned
you down oh you're looking that was a
wine bread in a sleeve I can sleeveless
top one [__] one triceps Galore yeah
yeah he was gay
I lied he was gay he was a grown ass gay
man huge and then yeah yeah yeah he was
walking around doing this he was like
what did you pinched out I was like bruh
I actually don't know because he's
winning that fight he was [__]
awesome walking past us and I was like
what would you do if you pinned you down
he looked at me and I said you know who
I'm talking about
I knew exactly who the [__] he was
talking about and the fear that ran
through my blood bro because there's
nothing you could do
oh God adrenaline wouldn't save you yeah
yeah because his adrenaline it will Top
yeah yeah on top because he's excited
yeah yeah
he's excited for the snack he's about to
yeah yeah bro that was mad all right let
me run it back
um T's so small I felt gay watching her
take her bra off okay stop wow yeah
that's not fair fam what's the wildest
place you've masturbated in reply turn
around
[Laughter]
that's just that's jokes
facts I'm turning around turn around in
fact I'm turning the [__] around scare
me
I just drove past a white people
barbecue and it didn't smell a damn
thing
raw no seasoning none I just want to
have a baby and see how it's gonna look
and then put it back
Oh my days oh that's jokes Grandma's
never claimed then it's always this is
my friend Mr Lenny
is that
this is my friend
oh that was funny men really be gullible
when they like you be believing you're a
good girl quite sweet no woman is good
you just have to find the last Eve or
the least evil one and beg her to stop
raw and beggar to stop damn they tell
you I would never do that to you and
they do it with a remix
[Laughter]
how were you caught cheating and did you
stop
I was engaged to Two Men and they didn't
know anything until I was caught wearing
the wrong ring chaos I don't want to
talk about
caught wearing the wrong ring the [__]
Jesus Christ yeah that's that's what I
got all right mad all right let's wrap
it there let's guys that was juicy man
oh God it came up towards the end of
course
um but anyway obviously guys
thank you for the zoom chat the other
day thank you for the love we're getting
on the reaction Channel and uh thank you
for [__] with us as always guys
[Music]
foreign